all right let's get into this first
story cause this is the greatest
headline i've ever seen
all right check this out this is from
local10.com
wild night in miami beach women twerk on
police car
two officers injured so my question
right away is uh did the cops get hurt
from the twerking undoubtedly
i'm imagining cops being like stop come
out with your legs up
you know all right okay so this is the
story's actually from march 12th but i
don't want to read it because it now
it's actually getting really crazy
they say it was a wild friday night in
south beach there were even women who
jumped on a police car to twerk
the city is swarming with spring
breakers miami beach officer ernesto
rodriguez a spokesman for the
department said two officers were
injured while dealing with a very large
crowd
near 8th street and ocean drive so
perhaps twerking was involved
while taking a subject into custody
officers were forced to utilize pepper
balls to disperse
members of the crowd who were disorderly
and surrounding officers
several subjects have been detained two
officers were injured
and have been transported to the
hospital more police officers are
enforcing the rules in the area of ocean
drive and collins
and washington avenues from 5th to 16th
street including espanola way
all packaged liquor sales ceased after
8pm so apparently now what's going on as
there's like this crazy curfew
we got the story just from today from
the guardian more than 1 000 arrests as
miami beach pushes spring break curfew
into april police condemned for use of
pepper balls to break up crowds now
apparently over a couple weeks
spring break curfew in place between
thursdays and sundays
now i don't know if you guys have seen
all these viral videos that have come
out it's crazy out there
a little bit of them that's pretty crazy
i mean are they using salt balls as well
that way maybe they can
salt and pepper a lot of these are
happening at restaurants
exactly perfect yeah right people aren't
paying their bills yeah
yeah do you see the video there's like a
video where two weight two guys wearing
aprons
just chasing a dude full speed down the
street and then he tries to get away
he's like
do walking then he ducks out he does
like a ninja roll oh yeah
and they start they like they pin him to
the ground and then drag him and then he
yeah he jumps out and then he rolls
dude what's going on with this man just
don't order as many drinks you know just
like order what you can pay for
it's shocking it's chaos like there's
there's a video so there's a there's a
threat going viral
that's talking about how these are not
people from miami like miami did really
well
and i guess what some people are saying
is that because florida is basically
like no covid
tons of like no lockdown tons of people
are like well then we have to go to
florida
because you can't do it in new york or
some of these blue states so they're all
coming to florida
red state for now swing state but red
for now where there's no restrictions
and they're just going crazy like
there's one video i saw where
apparently there's like cars in an
intersection and then a bunch of women
just walking down the street all just
stop and then it's like synchronized
twerking it's like the craziest thing
i mean that is gonna stop traffic if
you're low on like
people to help you cross the street like
just send a lady twerking out there and
she'll help divert traffic yeah if like
if you've got
kids coming out of school yeah yeah you
don't need to hire a crossing guard
anymore just
horsing guards twerking yes yeah road
torque
so so so for real so like why why is why
is this happening i mean it's just
because there's too many people they're
overwhelmed or people have been cooped
up for too long
they gotta just they're sick of they
haven't been twerking for like a year
now
true that's fair so given the
opportunity they just break out and
twerk yeah it seems like it's supposed
to be spring break from
school but a lot of those people i mean
is school even open or people
were even they even know they're doing
online school now
and they're just showing up and twerking
in the streets it's like i was wondering
you'd think that new york would be the
state that would be getting wrecked
because they're the one that shut down
but all those people that are flooding
to florida and wrecking florida there's
nothing to come to new york for what do
you get a flood in new york city
for like a hot dog stand like the are
the hot dog stands open
barely yeah they're like covered in
plastic it's it's a
really nice yeah it's like are you in
new york yeah yeah
comedy club some things are opening up
april 2nd so we'll see
there's some hope but it's it's the
city's dead it's like somebody sucked
the soul out of it
i don't know i saw a video from a guy
who was walking down the street in a
really
wealthy area saying that it was totally
fine oh oh well
having money helps i guess yeah yeah i
guess the poor areas that are shut down
it's interesting to see the amount of
chaos you get from
like totally apolitical things like
spring break
when there's just enough people who
don't care they go crazy the funny thing
about it is
we're probably seeing more like i guess
anarchy than you see with actual
anarchists not the weirdest thing
and i mean like left anarchist types i
don't like calling them anarchists
because the people get violent like
auntie they're not really anarchists but
let me rephrase that when antifa goes
out they fight with cops
these people are just like robbing small
businesses not paying bills
shutting down traffic it's random you
know
yeah it's totally random they're just
like you know what i can't twerk over
zoom i have to
go out into the street and do it your
legs yeah man
your muscles you gotta meet that you
gotta meet that spring break
boyfriend like in the first couple of
days and then you have a week of
you know hookups yeah 1 000 arrests
though smart yeah check us out the
guardian says police say they have
arrested more than a thousand people
about twice as many as last year
during this spring break season they say
the curfews are necessary to maintain
order according to the local cbs
affiliate city manager raul
aguila told the news station that he
believes visitors have traveled to miami
beach to engage in lawlessness
and anything goes party attitude aguila
claimed many visitors
are not patronizing local businesses or
spending tourism dollars during their
time in florida
then miami herald reported that police
have utilized pepper balls to disperse
crowds several times this spring break
season
describing the tactic as balls that are
fired at the ground that emit tear gas
forcing people within a certain distance
to move to avoid the eye
irritant the miami beach police chief
richard clements
told the paper that officers fired the
projectiles because the crowd
had begun to surge towards officers this
is crazy
quote i think officers felt threatened
at the time he said adding that at least
five officers have been injured during
spring break this year
video of large crowds and tear gassing
by police in the city have circulated
online
it's like on a scale of one to three of
of groups that engage in violent and
dangerous riots it's like the most
egregious number one is like
random people partying followed by
antifa
followed by like trump supporters just
because those are the only groups that
are actually engaging this i think
that's i'm kidding by the way
because antifa literally and black lives
matter burned down an entire city
but these people are getting super drunk
and that's when stuff can go haywire
like the animal comes out yeah yeah
there's definitely a venn diagram of
like people who would throw a chair
like through a window and it's like
spring breakers like antifa
yes yeah yep yep and tv on spring break
do you think these people are antifa
this is no
antifa people need to party too they
need to chill everybody got a party yeah
they got like sticks up their butt you
know they really need this maybe that's
what's happening
maybe they're so uptight you know they
show up to this party like
thinking they're gonna party but then
just everyone's having a good time and
then all sudden some dude throws a chair
through a window you know what i mean
and they've been so covered up for a
year they've been like
their costumes or whatever they're not
costumes they're get-ups it's like
they're all covered up they're pale
they need to get out true they need
their vitamin d no you know the some of
the most destructive riots i've seen
obviously not the most have been just
like sporting events and then you hear
this from a lot of people on the left
they'll be like
hokum win you know people riot over
their sports team winning it's not old
chris like
dude we criticized that it's crazy i
remember when the white sox won the
world series like however many years
like a decade ago
long time ago longer than a decade ago
man this was probably like
13 years ago uh they were crazy stories
like
my friends were telling me that a guy
there's just tons of people in the
street on the south side of chicago
and they're all just like screaming and
drunk and like shaking cars and flipping
them over
and then he said like a guy was driving
down archer and then just like swerve to
dodge the crowd
crashed into a pole and then jumped out
and started cheering
and then ran into the crowd like leaving
his car there like people go
crazy people get excited for their
sports teams
yeah they get i guess i guess i have to
wonder about this because like
is that what is what really drives
things like the you know minneapolis
when it got burned down
just random people taking advantage and
fluffing up the ranks
you know what i mean probably taking
advantage like these people that aren't
paying their tabs they're eating at
restaurants and then jumping
yup that's that's big that's big time
what's that sorry i mean
i'm just imagine like this is all so
pre-planned you're like
ordering you're like okay i don't want
to eat too much because when i get into
a fight
like i don't want to you know i'm gonna
throw it up i don't wanna be
full like i don't wanna yeah yeah puke
while i'm
throwing someone's head into into the
sidewalk yeah physical
physical activity after you eat a bunch
of food it's just it's like oh you know
it doesn't feel good you gotta you gotta
have a rest period
yeah so you know yeah a lot of wigs
coming off
i mean you gotta be prepared i don't
know it's giving me anxiety just
thinking about it this is freaking me
out yeah
like what to wear and i don't know how
it happens in these fights like
the women just end up like partially
nude like the thongs are out all of a
sudden you'll turn around like they'll
be fighting and then someone's top
someone's like
boobs will be out you'll be like how did
that oh god happening
because they're just it's just crazy to
hear this you know
i wasn't expecting it but i'm not
surprised i guess people have been
locked up for so long they've gone
insane
like a lot of people are just going
crazy so like you you're mentioning this
but also i think
when you factor in there's very few
places to actually go you get critical
mess
now they're just in miami and they're
just twerking and
stealing drinks and when you have pent
up energy it's like guys
the guys that wanna fight are gonna go
out looking for a fight and the girls
that like
want to fight you know i mean you're
going out kind of with that energy or
you're like just going to hook up it's
kind of fun videos are crazy yeah
there's a lot of videos like this
there's a big viral thread there's a lot
of racist threads too
because there's a lot of just like
people like sharing these specific
videos
but there's a lot of different people
doing a lot of crazy stuff
it's almost like a sporting event but
just no reason at all
right and there's anti-cop sentiment i i
imagine yeah
because i've read that like the cops
like this has been building up over time
it's not
it's obviously not a covet thing it's
like it's building up over time and like
going back to 2019 um a lot of these
cops i've read are afraid to basically
do their jobs because they don't want to
be accused of
racist policing yeah so when you get
like people blocking intersections and
twerking and the cops get hurt
i i bet there's a lot of people down
there they're probably not super
political
but the black lives matter narrative
really does permeate everything
so i we just went we're at the mall
they're hanging out and we went into
zoomies
and there was a poster on the wall that
was just like it was the weirdest thing
for me
to see in a zoomies it was like a poster
that said i stand with
black lives matter brianna taylor free
healthcare
increasing the minimum wage and i'm like
i'm in a mall
skate shop what is this like why is
there a poster for black lives matter
brianna taylor
but also like that i could get i suppose
but like the the
democrat talking points were on that too
and i'm just like it's kind of
weird to see i don't care whatever you
can put whatever poster you want i don't
care i'm gonna buy shoes or something
but it's just like when regular people
who normally don't engage in this stuff
are
getting hit with this i i'm willing to
bet there's anti-cop sentiment
for sure in these spring break riots
where they're just like half the police
you know what i mean why don't all of us
go to miami right now and start twerking
in the street i think that would help
narrative how'd that mean
i got a better idea why don't we get the
cops to twerk with the people in the
street that's what we needed
solidarity yeah in solidarity you know
like if it's enough twerking maybe it'll
be like a care bear stare we're like an
energy
everyone comes together and that's how
unity happens maybe maybe like
you know when all the cops took a knee
during the black lives matter stuff
maybe the cops need to take a twerk
yes and they should all go out there to
apologize for using pepper balls on
people
take a torch guys twerk during the
national anthem at a basketball game
or whatever and definitely dissolve
tension it would crack people up
freak people out do you think they're
gonna cancel spring break next year
how can you cancel spring break i don't
know you can't cancel it it's not it's
not really a thing it's like people just
showed up
people just went to florida and then
there was too many people
i'll tell you what freaks me out is like
is this what people do when there's too
many people
somebody somebody messaged us like last
week about the rat utopia experiment oh
yeah have you ever heard of this
no they created the space where they put
a bunch of rats
in this rat house you mean new york city
yeah so basically they made a model of
new york and i'm kidding they took like
a rat city
and they gave him an unlimited supply of
food and water and whatever
and they just like went nuts apparently
started eating each other
some just literally just dropped dead so
like they reproduced and reproduced
and then eventually they reached like
this massive population but there was
still just free food
nothing to worry about and then they the
rats apparently started breaking down
going crazy
eating each other and just dying and so
i'm wondering like
you get too many people and this is what
we see like i was in new york when i
can't remember which new york team won
the super bowl or something was back in
like 2012 i think
i don't know i don't know sports you
guys give me the right year people were
just like throwing garbage cans and
trash everywhere just flipping things
over
and it was just tens of thousands of
people walking through the streets just
trashing everything
for for no reason yeah if somebody else
starts doing it it's easier to
chime in i guess thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.comcast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you